The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So my goal
for today is twofold.
The first is, we've looked at
the history of the internet
in the '60s and the '70s.
And today, my goal
is to tell you
about what happened in
the '80s and the '90s,
as well as the last decade.
And we'll do that
maybe 30, 35 minutes.
But I want to tell you about
two interesting problems that
got solved, both related
to topics we've studied.
The first is on how the internet
dealt with a serious problem
called congestion
collapse, which
happened in the mid-1980s,
where TCP, the transmission
protocol at the time, was
still the dominant protocol
in the world, didn't have
many of the new ideas
that it now has.
In fact, the implementation
of TCP in the 1980s
was almost exactly
the implementation
of your sliding window
protocol from the second lab,
from the second task
of the last lab.
And in fact, as
some of you are--
I think Tyler
posted it on Piazza,
there was a particular
way in which
he had dealt with the windowing
scheme that happened to do
better than the lab solution.
And I remarked there that the
reason the lab solutions are
the way they are are a
little bit more general
than the particular topology.
But the topology that I
picked was specifically
picked in the lab so
you didn't have to worry
about congestion happening.
But today, I'll tell you what
happens when congestion happens
and the solutions
that were adopted.
And it'll be a little bit
of a preview to 6.033.
You'll study this topic
at some length in 6.033.
The other problem
I want to tell you
about today through
these remarks
is about how easy it is to
hijack routes on the internet.
And I'll go through
some examples
of this happening in reality.
I mean, it is literally
something a bunch of-- you
know, you can do
it in your dorm.
You just have to convince
some sort of-- pretend
you're an ISP, or set yourself
up as a small internet service
provider.
And you can actually
wreak a fair bit of damage
onto the rest of the world
if you're so inclined,
and then pretend that it
was just a, you know, error.
So those are the
two technical ideas.
I mean, none of this stuff
is really on the quiz,
though it's probably helpful
to think about these things
about route hijacking
because those apply to some
of the concepts we've studied.
But a lot of this is just
for-- out of your own interest.
And I'm hoping to
pique your curiosity
so later courses
in the department
would be interesting.
OK, so in the 1980s,
the people designing
the protocols of the internet
started to get organized.
And as you recall,
Vint Cerf and Bob Kahn
were the leaders of the effort.
There was a big community
of people contributing
to what became the internet.
And back in those days,
it was still the ARPANET.
ARPA had funded
this entire project.
And it was starting
to be successful.
In the 1980s, rapid
growth started.
People said how the
internet is booming,
and how it's exploding
at 80% or 90% a year.
It's been growing at
about 80% to 90% a year
since about 1983 or 1984.
This explosive growth has been
happening for several decades
now.
Dave Clark, who was
a senior research
scientist at MIT and on the
faculty in our department,
was designated as the
internet's chief architect.
And one of the things he did was
to get the community organized
and formalize the creation
of internet standards.
You know, you have all
these different companies
and organizations and
universities coming together.
How do you
standardize protocols?
And the argument-- the
approach they came up with
was called the Internet
Engineering Task
Force, or IETF.
And they would write
these proposals.
There had been this trend
of writing these proposals
for people to comment on, called
RFCs, or Request For Comments.
And now, there are several
thousand requests for comment.
Nowadays, requests for
comment are after the comments
have been made.
Usually, you go through
an internet draft stage.
And by the time it's
a request for comment,
it pretty much means that
the comments have already
been done.
But historically, they
were requests for comment,
so they called it
request for comment.
So if you ever go to a company
where you're asked to--
lots of things that are on
internet request for comments.
And often, people are
asked to implement
pieces of various standards.
And you typically
look at this document,
and you try to see if there's
someone written code around it.
And then you adapt it
or write it from scratch
to the specification.
So it specifies the protocols.
And the interesting
part of the standard
was very much in keeping
with the general approach
of the internet ethos,
which was to try
to make everything be open.
There are many standards
bodies in the world.
The IEEE has various committees.
The International
Telecommunications Union
does the various
telephone standards.
There's many, many standards.
And often, they're
based on voting.
And voting means that
people horse trade.
You know, you have
a favorite feature,
I have a favorite feature.
They're both pretty crappy
features, but you know,
I'll vote for your feature
if you vote for mine.
And people end up horse trading.
And in the IETF, in the good
old days, this kind of stuff
didn't happen.
Now, it's changed.
But in the good old days,
there was this quote,
it says, we reject kings,
presidents, and voting.
We believe in rough
consensus and running code.
The idea was that you
show me what it does.
Allow people to
experiment with it.
And only after we
see some prototypes
and some actual
experiments in the lab will
we even consider making
it into a standard.
And this was the good
old days of the internet
in which things were on rough
consensus and running code.
So it wasn't around, you
know what, let's just vote,
and we'll get all our
lousy features in just
because we care enough
about it personally.
A big break happened
in 1982 when
the US Department
of Defense decided
that proprietary
technology was not the way
to go with networking,
and standardized on TCP/IP
as the standard.
And back in those days,
the Defense Department
was a huge consumer of IT.
It still is, but back then,
it was just hugely dominant.
And they could really
influence how the world went.
In 1983, MIT created a
Athena, the first really
big, large-scale
computing project.
We still have Athena machines.
And it showed how to
build campus-area networks
and campus-area technologies.
They built distributed
file systems,
they built systems
like Kerberos.
And in fact, they were
one of the first groups,
the first networks to experience
network congestion problems
because everybody started using
the network to do their work
rather than have their own
computers at their desk
or use the terminal to log in
to some remote mainframe, which
was the way in which
things used to be done.
I mentioned last
time that in 1984, we
created the domain name system.
This is the system that
goes between domain names
like mit.edu to an IP address.
And before that, it was an FTP--
how many people
have heard of FTP?
A few of you, OK--
File Transfer Protocol.
Nobody really uses
that these days.
But you used to download
this-- every night,
computers would download it from
one machine located, I believe,
in California.
And it didn't really
scale, you know?
And people decided
that you needed
to get organized and build
a domain name system.
In 1985, ARPA was--
the Defense Department
was starting
to get out a little
bit of maintaining
the entire
communication network.
And the National
Science Foundation
started taking over the
running of the backbone,
connecting all the non-military
networks in the United States.
And this led to the NSFNET.
I'll have more to say about
NSFNET in a little bit.
There were two big growth
problems that were experienced.
The first was congestion,
and the second
had to do with how addresses
started running out,
and we had to deal with
problems in the routing system.
So I want to talk
about congestion.
In 1986, the
internet experienced
the first of a series
of congestion collapses.
A congestion collapse
is a situation
where you end up
with a picture that
looks like this,
where if you were
to draw the offered load on a
network, or any system for that
matter--
which is just how many
people are clamoring
to get access to the network and
send their data on the network.
If you were to plot the
throughput that you get,
or the utilization that
you get from the network,
you typically would see a
curve that looks like this.
As the offered load grows,
you might see a somewhat
linear increase in the
throughput with slope 1
because the network
isn't congested,
no packets are being dropped.
You push some data in,
you get the data out.
The throughput tracks
the offered load.
And at some point, you reach
the capacity of the link,
or of the network in general.
And you might end up with
a flat curve like that.
And that's fine.
What you would
really like to do is,
as the overload load
keeps increasing
and the throughput
saturates at the capacity--
of course, that means that--
what does it mean?
Either the delays are
growing to infinity
or packets are being
dropped, right?
And what you would really like
intuitively is for the sources
to realize that packets
are being dropped
or they're not being delivered
in time, so maybe slow down.
Something has to happen.
But congestion collapse
is a worse phenomenon.
What happens is, beyond a point,
your throughput [INAUDIBLE]
drops, sometimes precipitously,
and it might go down to zero.
So people were running
network applications--
you know, FTP and remote
logins and so forth,
email and so forth.
And what they were finding was
that you could be running--
the ratio between what the
capacity of the network was
and what you were getting
when you were running
was a factor of
100 to 1,000 worse.
So this is a real collapse.
I mean, you wouldn't be able
to get anything through.
So people were talking about
going from, in those days,
tens of kilobits per
second to bits per second.
In fact, there was
a joke that there
was a path in Berkeley between
the University of California
and Lawrence Berkeley
Labs, which is probably
400 meters from each other.
And the network rate was such
that you could actually run up
the hill with a
tape drive and you'd
get 100 times higher
throughput than what you were
getting through the network.
And you know, this was not
even running up very fast.
So this was a serious problem.
This problem was dealt
with by multiple people
who were working on it.
And it led to a
set of algorithms
where the idea was
that you would like--
because all these switches and
routers were already deployed,
people were interested
in end-to-end solutions
to the problem.
By end-to-end, I
mean solutions you
could deploy at the centers and
the receivers in the network
without worrying about what the
network was doing in between.
The actual algorithm
that we all run today
had its roots in an algorithm
developed by Van Jacobson
at Lawrence Berkeley Lab.
And there's a lot
of work that has
been done since then by many
other people in the community
as well.
And in parallel,
there were people
inside of Digital Equipment
Corporation over here
in Massachusetts working
on similar problems.
And they came up with ideas.
And both these
ideas were basically
the same idea, more or
less, except in the detail.
And they also resembled what
we've seen with MAC protocols.
The idea is that if the network
is working reasonably well,
we're going to try to
be greedy and start
to send faster and faster.
At some point, we're going to
find that the network doesn't
work so well.
And we can determine that in
one of a few different ways.
One way to determine that is
that packets start getting
lost.
And we will assume
that packets are
lost because queues overflow
and congestion happens.
We might also
alternatively assume
that as queues in
the network grow,
packets get delayed more and
more when the network starts
to get congested.
And if we find that the
roundtrip times are starting
to increase, maybe we determined
that congestion has happened.
Now, there's been 30
years of literature.
The problem has not yet
been completely solved.
And in fact, we have now
an active research project
going on in my group
about how to deal
with these problems in the
context of video and video
conferencing in cellular,
in wireless networks
that you run with your
phone, on your phone.
So it's still an problem,
lots of interesting research.
But the basic idea is
that you have to adapt
to what the network is doing.
And the way you adapt is by
watching things in the network.
You watch where the
packets are being lost.
You watch whether
delays are growing.
You might watch
what the receiver's
getting-- you know, how fast
is the receiver getting data
from the center and the network.
And the intuition
is the following--
let's suppose that we were to
pick the correct window size.
This goes to the sliding
window and the window size
that you use.
We said that the right
value of the window size
is roughly the
bandwidth-delay product, where
the bandwidth-delay product is
the product of the bottleneck
link rate multiplied by
the minimum roundtrip time.
But the problem is the
bottleneck-link rate
is not fixed.
It is in the lab we
studied, but in reality, you
have many connections sharing
the network, many applications
sharing the network.
And people come and go, so
the rate keeps changing.
At one moment, you might be
getting 100 kilobits a second.
The next moment, you might be
getting a megabit per second.
And on wireless networks,
it's even worse.
Quite literally,
if I were to start
an application on my phone now,
connecting to Verizon or AT&T,
and if I step out
of this room, it's
quite likely that the actual
[INAUDIBLE] experience
by my phone might change
by a factor of four
or a factor of eight
within two seconds.
And that has to do, of
course, with the fact that
the signal-to-noise ratio--
I mean, we're surrounded
by thick walls and metal.
And the moment I go out,
it's going to be different.
So how do you deal
with this problem?
There's this one
basic idea that's
used that's a fundamental
idea, very important idea.
And it's called
conservation of packets.
It's the same idea that
you saw when you built
your sliding window protocol.
It says that when you put in
a packet into the network,
and the packet
reaches the other end,
and you get an acknowledgment
for the other end,
it means that one packet
has left this pipe.
If you view this
as that picture,
as you see in that
picture up there,
packets are like
water entering a pipe.
And then they leave the
pipe, and then another one
comes back.
If you have managed to
somehow, by some magic,
pick the appropriate
window size,
then conservation of packets
is a good principle for you
to apply.
Because what it says is
that the only time you're
allowed to put one more
packet into the network
is when you're sure that a
packet has left the network.
And the way you know that a
packet has left the network
is because you receive an
acknowledgment for that packet.
Now of course, this assumes that
you know the right window size.
Conservation of packets has
another really nice advantage,
which is that-- let's
say that you think
you have the right window size.
But in fact, more
traffic comes in,
and the bandwidth, the rate
at which you can send data,
reduces.
What's going to happen is that
because other traffic came in,
the roundtrip times
are going to grow,
which means that
acknowledgments to your packets
are going to come back a little
slower, which means that you
have a natural slowdown.
Because acknowledgments
come slower,
you naturally slow down and
send packets a little slower.
And then of course, then,
if the congestion persists,
packets are going to get lost.
And when packets
get lost, the trick
is you have to reduce
your window size.
So let's say you're
running at a window
size in your lab of 50 packets
when you implement this.
If you find that packets
are getting lost,
you should drop
your window size.
And one way to drop the
window size that TCP uses
is to reduce it by one half.
And then every time you
find that acknowledgments
are coming back, you
get a little greedy
and you try to increase
the window size.
And there are many ways to
increase the window size.
Now, all of this
stuff requires a way,
when you start the
connection, when you start
an application, what do you do?
And I think you pointed out an
idea the last time when I first
talked about this problem,
which is in the beginning,
you let your window
size be one packet, OK?
So you start your window
size at one packet.
So it's like stop and wait.
So at the beginning
of a connection,
If I were to draw time here
against the window size,
you start at one packet, and
you just ship that packet out.
It takes an entire roundtrip
to get to the other side,
you get an acknowledgment back.
At that point, with
regular stop and wait,
you keep the same
window size of 1,
and you send one more packet.
You're not being greedy enough.
So one thing you can do is,
when you get one acknowledgment,
you double the window size,
or rather, increase the window
size by 1.
Every time you get
an acknowledgement,
you increase the
window size by 1.
So the rule is, on
[INAUDIBLE] you take w
and you go to w plus 1.
What does that do?
Well, after one
roundtrip, if I draw
this in multiples of
the roundtrip time,
this is one RTT,
this is two RTTs,
this is three
RTTs, and so forth.
So at the beginning,
at the zeroth RTT,
your window size is 1.
You get an acknowledgment,
you make your window size
be 2, right, 1 plus 1.
So at this point,
your window size is 2.
What is the window
size after two RTTs?
It's 4 because-- why is it 4?
When you send out two packets--
yes?
AUDIENCE: You get
two [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: You get
two [INAUDIBLE] back.
So for the first one,
you went from 2 to 3.
Then, you went from 3 to 4.
So your window size grows to 4.
And then out here,
if there's no losses,
then you haven't yet reached--
the window size
hasn't yet reached
the bandwidth-delay
product of the connection,
you're increasing exponentially.
So this is at 8, and so forth.
You're growing fairly rapidly.
And at some point, you're
going to grow too fast.
Your window size
is going to exceed
the bandwidth-delay
product plus the queue size
of the bottleneck, causing
a packet to be lost.
And at that point, you
can do a bunch of things.
But one thing you can do
is to drop the window size
by a factor of 2.
So whenever that happens,
if there's a packet loss,
you drop by a factor of 2.
And you could continue to
try to grow exponentially,
but that would be stupid.
Because you would
grow exponentially,
and if the network
conditions haven't changed,
you're going to again drop.
So at this point, you
could do something else.
And what TCP does is to start
to grow linearly, rather
than exponential growth.
Once you experience congestion,
you start to grow linearly.
And then maybe you
experience congestion here,
you drop by one half
and grow linearly.
And you have this sort
of sawtooth behavior.
And for most web
connections that
involve downloading a
small amount of data,
you end over here.
For video and everything
else, you go all the way.
And this is one strategy.
There are many, many others.
And like I said, in
various kinds of networks,
like wireless
networks, it turns out
this approach is not
really that good.
And there are open questions
around how you should actually
design the system.
Does everyone understand
the basic idea?
This is an example of
adaptive congestion control.
You'll look at this in 6.033
and in 6.829 in more detail
if you took those classes.
Any questions?
OK.
All right, I'm now
moving over to the 1990s.
Nothing else interesting
happened in the '80s.
But in the 1990s,
more things happened.
ARPANET essentially ended as far
as universities and everybody
else was concerned.
And in fact, it transitioned
into-- you know,
there were separate
military networks.
And in 1991, Tim Berners-Lee,
who is also now here at MIT,
a professor, invented a little
thing called the WorldWideWeb,
called with one world.
WorldWideWeb was the
name of the program.
And I found this thing
which was very interesting.
So he wrote a proposal
in 1989, I think,
to CERN, where he was
working, to his boss at CERN.
And it was called,
"Information Management--
A Proposal."
And there were all
these things, you
know, about how what became
the web should work, with links
and so forth.
And his boss at the
time, on top wrote,
"vague but interesting" as
his feedback on the proposal.
Presumably, the interesting
part trumped the vague part,
and allowed him to actually
proceed on this project, which
became the World Wide Web.
Now, obviously, it's been
tremendously successful.
Now, by the
mid-1990s, the NSFNET,
which was the backbone
connecting the US, various US
organizations, the
government decided
to essentially get out of
the internet service provider
business.
Or rather, the
government decided not
to fund that activity anymore.
And many of you
have probably heard
about this joke about Al
Gore inventing the internet
and not inventing the
internet, and people saying he
didn't invent the internet.
Well, there's sort of a
little bit of truth in this.
Al Gore was very instrumental
in the government
kind of getting out of
the internet business,
and was involved in
committees that set up
regulations that led to
internet service providers,
commercial internet service
providers actually forming,
and commercial ISPs
starting to take off,
which was a really, really
big change for the internet.
Because no longer was
it the case that there's
this one organization
and one backbone network
that connects MIT and Harvard
and everybody else together,
and all the companies together.
You had many, many people who
could offer internet service,
and in fact compete
with each other.
The idea was the
internet service
providers or different
network operators have
to cooperate with
each other because we
are interested in connecting
everybody on the internet
together.
But they also compete
with each other.
And their reason to compete
is they compete for customers.
If I'm a customer of Verizon,
I'm not a customer of Comcast,
for example.
And yet, Verizon and
Comcast and other ISPs
have to actually cooperate
to get packets through.
So how do you do this?
And it turns out that
this is a tougher problem
than you might think.
And the world-- people
invented this protocol
called BGP, or the
Border Gateway protocol,
which uses an idea
that we've seen.
It uses Path Vector
to solve this problem.
And I'll talk a little
bit about that as well.
The other thing that
happened in the internet
was that IP addresses
started to get depleted.
And we saw why the
last time-- everybody
wanted those Class B addresses.
And now, in fact
quite literally,
there are no more IP
version 4 IP addresses.
And so there was a lot
of work done on moving
to other versions of IP.
But the part that is
interesting is this idea
of classless addressing.
So the idea was rather
than have organizations
that either have to have
2 to the 24 addresses,
or 2 to the 16 addresses,
or 2 to the 8 addresses,
let's allow organizations to
have any number of addresses.
So I want to tell you
a little bit about what
an IP address means,
because everyone
has seen an IP address.
I want to explain what it
means, and how it really
actually works.
So if you look at an
IP address, 18.31.0.82,
which is one of
my machines, that
dotted decimal notation
with human-readable numbers
used to make sense
in the old days.
It used to be that this is
a Class A address from MIT.
It's 18 dot whatever, and
MIT owned all of that stuff.
Now, that also
happens to be true,
but as far as the network
infrastructure and the switches
are concerned, this
thing is nothing more
than a 32-bit number
that looks like that, OK?
Now, when a packet
with that number
shows up at the switch
with a destination
address with that number,
really what happens
is that the switch,
the router does not
have an entry for every
one of those destinations
in the world.
If it did, it just would
be too much information.
So what it has is
information corresponding
to a certain prefix.
Now, that prefix could
be of arbitrary length.
It could have an entry in
it with just the first 8
bits, which would signify
that all packets that show up
with that first prefix of 8
bits would have to be forwarded
according to a rule--
according to the link that was
set for those first 8 bits.
Or it could have an entry in
the routing table for 16 bits.
the routing table for 19 bits,
or whatever.
And that depends on how
the routing system--
how we advertise the routes,
and what it contains.
So there's an
important lesson here.
When a switch advertises
a route for a destination,
on the internet, the destination
is not the destination of--
is not the IP address
of an endpoint.
But what that destination
is is a prefix
that represents a range of
IP addresses, all of which
are forwarded the same
way by the switch.
So one way of writing
this in notation
that we can understand as human
beings more conveniently is
this idea of writing
it as 18 slash 8.
What that means is--
this notation stands for all IP
addresses which have the first
eight bits in common,
which will be 0001011010,
which stands for the
human readable number 18.
And it contains all 2 to the
24 addresses corresponding
to that prefix.
So as another example,
if I have that
in my routing table
with a slash 17,
it stands for 2 to
the 15 consecutive IP
addresses, all of which share
the first 17 bits in common,
OK?
Does this makes sense?
So this is what an
IP address means.
And as far as a
switch is concerned,
a routing table
entry is not the IP--
it's not a destination
IP address.
But it's something in this form.
It contains a prefix, and
it contains a [INAUDIBLE]..
So in human notation, 18.31
slash 17 would be 17--
2 to the 15 bits, which share
the first 17 bits in common.
So what this means is
that with this notation,
inside the forwarding
table, you can have an entry
for one IP address, or two,
or four, or eight, or 16,
all the way up to whatever
the maximum is, right?
So it allows us to build
networks of different sizes,
and let that network's
identifier be known
to the rest of the internet.
Now, in principle, you could
put every host in the network.
And that would mean that you
have an entry that-- each
of which looks like a slash 32.
If I did a slash 32, it meant
that it's an individual IP
address.
But that wouldn't scale.
And so we want to allow
people the flexibility
of having very
different ranges sitting
inside the routing system.
And there's one more rule.
And this rule is
important because I
want to tell you this
rule-- because I'm
going to tell you how YouTube
was hijacked by an ISP
in Pakistan.
And it relies on
your understanding
this particular forwarding rule.
And then I'll tell you
about how an ISP in China
hijacked 15% of the internet
for a couple of hours,
for a few hours.
And that didn't
require this rule,
but it's two examples I
want to tell you about.
But let me explain the rule--
the forwarding at a
switch uses an idea called
the longest prefix match.
So what that means is
that if you have entries
in your forwarding table--
let's take those two examples.
And let's say I have an entry
in the forwarding table.
This is a particular switch,
I have a forwarding table
or a routing table.
And the first entry
says 18 slash 8.
So what this means is it's 2
to the 24 addresses that share
the first eight bits,
which is whatever
corresponds to 18.0.0--
whatever it is, right?
And then let's say I
have another entry, which
is some 18.31 slash 17.
And what that would
be, of course,
is 2 to the 15 addresses.
And the prefix would be shown
in that picture there, whatever
the first 17 bits--
so some 17 bits.
Now, if the switch received
a packet with an IP address,
and that IP address matched
multiple entries-- you know,
you might have other
entries sitting here.
Let's say that I have
128.32 slash something.
And I might have
various other entries
sitting in my forwarding table.
When a packet arrives,
it may, in general,
match multiple
entries here, right?
Because the packet has a certain
bit string in its destination
address.
And that destination address
now matches multiple of these.
It could match one or more
of these entries here.
What an IP router does
when it gets such a packet
is to find the entry which
matches in the longest prefix.
In other words, the
routing table entry
that corresponds to
the longest prefix
match between the destination
address of the packet
and between the entry
in the forwarding table
is what you use to
send the packet on.
So if you got a packet
that was 18.31.6.5
and it happened to match this
entry, it would go on one link.
Let's say this was link 1.
And if you have got this other
thing that didn't match this,
but matched that, you might
have a different link.
Let's call it link 0.
So the output link that you use
depends on the longest prefix
match.
And MIT and many organizations
use this extremely well.
So I was remarking to some of
you at the end of last time
that--
You know, it's funny, MIT
has multiple internet service
providers.
And it turns out that if
I use this network here
and I download-- you
know, I go to linux.org,
which is a place you
could download Linux code.
If I go from here, it so
happens that MIT users
level three, which is I think
the world's biggest, or US's
biggest internet service
provider to get those packets.
The same thing-- if I just go
up to [? Stata, ?] and I connect
to the [? Stata ?] wireless,
and go to linux.org,
packets from linux.org come back
to me through a different ISP,
Cogent.
So MIT has decided that it wants
to load balance its traffic.
So it advertises the prefix
corresponding to the network
in this room, whatever the
Wi-Fi network in this room,
through one of the ISPs.
And it advertises the
other prefix in Stat
through the other ISP.
And it does it presumably
to load balance traffic.
And it also has this idea
that if one of those links
were to fail, it would
switch the traffic
through the other link.
Organizations do
this because they
would like to provide
good service to the people
inside their organization.
So the longest
prefix match is very
crucial to how this stuff
really kind of works.
So keep that in mind.
I'm going to come back to this.
On to the next slide.
In the rest of the 1990s, a few
interesting things happened.
One of them was that work
started on this new proposal
for IP called IPv6, which said,
let's not use 32-bit addresses.
Let's go to 128-bit
bigger addresses
and try to solve the
address depletion problem.
IPv6 has taken a
really, really long time
to get deployed for reasons
I won't go into here.
But it seems to
be happening now.
But people keep saying that
it seems to be happening now.
I said that three
years ago when I
did the wrap-up in this class.
So some time-- at some
point in the future,
that statement will
actually be true.
Now, you know, everybody
knows about Google
reinventing how search is done,
and it starts to dominate.
Another thing that
happened in 1998
was content
distribution networks
started getting created.
And these are networks that
you deploy as overlay networks
atop the internet to
serve content better,
in a more reliable way.
Now, in the 2000s,
the internet matured.
And I have the top
five things that I
think happened in the networking
industry and the networking
world in 2000.
So this dot-com bust happened,
and then 9/11 happened.
The first thing that
happened was the rise
of peer-to-peer networks.
I'm sure many of
you have used this--
Gnutella and Freenet,
BitTorrent is the latest one.
There was a lot of research
done, including here at MIT,
on how you build these
peer-to-peer networks,
the idea being, you don't have
a central point of failure.
And you can use this
to distribute files
extremely efficiently.
I mean, BitTorrent is
still highly dominant.
And distributed hash
tables like Chord,
which was developed here, and
other schemes that are used now
by systems like Skype, they
are used inside data centers
like Amazon.
If you go to Amazon
and buy stuff,
it uses a system
called Dynamo, which
is a key value store that
basically builds a distributed
hash table.
So it's had a lot of
impact, both in data centers
and in systems like Skype.
The second thing
that happened was
that in the early to mid-2000s,
security became a huge deal.
People started attacking
the internet, which
came as somewhat of a
surprise to people who grew up
in the good old
days of the internet
where, as I mentioned
last time, computers
with root passwords that
were empty because everybody
could be trusted.
And then they found that as
people started making money
on the internet,
people started trying
to attack the internet as well.
Denial of service
attacks started,
where people would launch
attacks on websites.
And they would often
use it to extort money.
This would be like,
if you don't pay me,
I'm going to continue to
pummel your website so
that you can't sell
flowers, or whatever it
is you were doing on the web.
People found
vulnerabilities in software,
and there were many worms that
spread, often pretty quickly.
SQL slammer is a particularly
interesting one of these.
We studied this stuff in 829
and in 6.033 in some detail.
But this was remarkable
because in 30 minutes,
it clogged the world's networks.
I mean, here's a
picture of a screenshot.
This was at 5:30 in the morning,
I guess UTC, Greenwich Time.
And you know,
nothing's going on.
And then half an hour
later, the blue splotches
show the networks
that were clogged.
And almost every computer
that was vulnerable to this--
there weren't that
many computers,
relative to the
world's computers,
that were vulnerable to this.
But all these
networks got hammered,
and in fact, traffic
came to a halt.
And this worm showed
that the power
of spreading-- if
machines trust each other,
either implicitly
or explicitly, it's
very easy to actually find a
vulnerability in one and then
spread very, very quickly.
So a lot of work was done on
how to handle worm attacks.
A lot of this has to do
with putting things inside
of networks, which is
running at high speeds,
to identify patterns that--
in the payload of--
in the data that's
being sent in packets to quickly
identify that this corresponds
to a worm, and then throw
those packets away before they
hit the actual endpoints.
Right now, we don't see
too many worms spreading.
The ones that spread now
are slow-spreading worms
that are often spread
by human contact.
It's like people clicking on
links they shouldn't click on.
It runs the program, finds a
vulnerability on their machine,
and then it resides
on their machine.
And often, these are then used
to create these big botnets
that are used to launch
denial-of-service attacks,
or are often used to send spam
and do other things like that.
So they're still going on,
but you don't hear about them
in the newspaper.
Spam became a huge problem.
And it continues to be
somewhat of a problem,
though these days, the
distinction between spam
and internet marketing
is kind of coming down--
the gap's closing.
But by and large, spam
now is, while I wouldn't
say it's a solved
problem, it's generally
combated by big
organizations that
have enough data, enough
email coming in that they
can identify spam and
then filter those away.
Route hijacking is
the other problem.
That remains a
huge vulnerability.
So I want to tell you about two
examples of route hijacking.
And I don't think there's easy--
the technical side
of this problem,
we understand how to solve.
But how to deploy good
solutions is still unclear.
So the first example is from--
this problem has been going on.
Every three years, you see a
big route hijacking problem.
The first one was from 2008--
I think it was
2008, where YouTube
was unavailable to
people for a few hours
everywhere in the world.
Now, you could argue
whether watching cats dance
or whatever is not important.
But the fact is that
YouTube has a lot of money.
Google has a lot of
money, and even they
were vulnerable to this trouble.
The second example was
a little different.
China Telecom managed
to get about 15%,
roughly speaking, of
the internet traffic
to go through them.
Now, the interesting
thing about that attack
is that it wasn't
clear it was an attack.
I should just say that
error, or failure, was
that people didn't even notice.
Because unlike
YouTube, where you go,
you couldn't get your data,
and then people noticed it,
and then they were scrambling
to solve the problem,
with the Chinese attack, or
the Chinese vulnerability,
what happened was
that China Telecom
managed to divert the
traffic that wasn't supposed
to go through them-- to them.
And then they
forwarded the traffic
on to the rest of
their destinations,
the actual destinations.
So you would find
things like, instead
of my latency being
100 milliseconds,
it might be 500
milliseconds, which is--
you may not even notice.
Or sometimes, you
notice it, and you
go, ah, yeah, that's just the
internet being the internet,
you know?
Sometimes, that happens.
But the fact is that they
were able to-- an ISP
was able to essentially divert
a large fraction of the world's
traffic.
And both these
attacks fundamentally
stem from the following
problem, which
is that at the end of
the day, despite all
of this investment
into the internet,
and the importance
of the internet,
and the amount of money in it,
internet routing works because
of essentially an honor code.
It's like, ISPs at some
level, internet service
providers and organizations
trust each other.
And there's this
transitive trust,
which is I might trust you,
and you might trust her.
And implicitly, the
way routing works
is that ends up in
me trusting her.
Because I trust
everything you tell me,
and you happen to
trust everything
she tells you, which means that
if she were to make a mistake,
and you were to believe
it, then in essence,
everybody else in the world
is vulnerable to this problem.
So let me explain what happened
in the case of YouTube,
because it's reflective
of how things really work.
So here's this little ISP
called Pakistan Telecom.
Tiny, tiny ISP, you know?
Hardly anyone uses it outside--
I mean, everyone in
Pakistan probably uses it.
But in the grand scale of
things, it's completely tiny.
So they end up
connecting to a bunch
of people outside in
different parts of the world.
And one of the
people they ended up
connecting to was another ISP
out in Hong Kong called PCCW.
And these guys connect to
the rest of the internet.
And presumably, Pakistan Telecom
connects to other people--
I don't know.
Now, here's what happened.
Now, where does YouTube
fit into all this?
You know, YouTube is
sitting somewhere over here.
And presumably,
it's not directly--
I mean, these guys have
nothing to do with each other.
These guys are connected to some
other big ISPs and small ISPs.
And eventually, there a set
of internet service providers
that somehow constitute
the internet.
And each of these
is independent.
Each of these is known as
an anonymous system, or AS.
And each of these
autonomous systems
has a number, a 16-bit number.
MIT is an anonymous system.
And because MIT was very
early in the internet,
MIT'S autonomous
system number is 3.
But right now, there
are many, many ISPs.
You know, right
now, you can have--
there are tens of thousands
of autonomous systems--
I don't know, 35,000, 40,000,
45,000, something like that.
We're number 3!
So anyway--
AUDIENCE: Who's number one?
PROFESSOR: Who's number one?
BBN.
Yeah, BBN.
I don't know what AS2 is.
BBN, of course, is number one.
But actually, that
number is owned
by somebody who acquired
BBN and who acquired--
somebody acquires it.
Now, here's an interesting
thing that's happening--
these autonomous
system numbers--
I remember I was a
very young graduate
student when people were talking
about these autonomous numbers.
And I remember these
mailing list discussions.
I wasn't working on
this problem then,
I worked on it much later.
But people were
saying, yeah, 16 bits
is plenty enough for an
autonomous system identifier.
Because remember,
NSFNET was one.
There was one internet
service provider.
And in the early '90s, mid '90s
people were talking about ISPs,
and they said, oh,
16 bits is plenty.
And I remember there were
some people, actually
graduate students
who were saying,
maybe we should make it 32 bits?
Because people remembered that--
you know, the internet started--
you remember those old things
on the internet
where people said,
8 bits for a network
identifier are plenty enough.
And of course, they got screwed.
So anyway, what's
happening now, of course,
is the older guys were saying
16 bits is plenty enough
because we don't have too
much overhead on packets.
And they put in 16 bits.
And now, we're at
45,000 or 50,000.
And guess what,
there's a proposal
now on how do you-- how
the heck do you extend this
to more than 2 to the
16 autonomous system,
because now, the
internet is growing.
So you know, if ever
you're given an opportunity
to design the number
of bits for something--
and you will always have
to do something-- just pick
something much, much
bigger than you imagine,
and then double it.
Because it's always--
you'll never get it right.
So anyway, each of
these autonomous systems
has an identifier in it, OK?
And each of these
guys, when they
make an announcement
in the routing system,
the way it works is that
you create your identifier,
and then you tell people all of
the IP prefixes that you own,
OK?
So when I create my distance
vector, or in this case
a path vector advertisement,
if I am autonomous system 3,
I have a set of IP addresses.
So MIT might have 18
dot whatever slash 8.
MIT has 128 dot something
slash-- let's say 19.
MIT has a whole slew
of these IP addresses
that they've acquired.
And what they're going to say
is, I'm autonomous system 3,
and I know how to get to these
guys because I own these guys.
This is the origin announcement.
And then other people-- you
know, MIT might-- this is AS3.
MIT sends it to its ISPs, and
they send it to their ISPs.
And every time an
autonomous system
receives multiple advertisements
along different paths
for the same prefix,
they pick one.
They select among them.
They have some rules
to select among them.
And these rules have to do
with the length of the path
between autonomous systems.
They have to do with
how much you're paying.
So for example, MIT might
be getting a better deal
from Cogent than from Level 3.
And so it would want more of
its traffic to come from Cogent.
And therefore, it would
decide that it would only
advertise certain of its
addresses on certain paths.
So there's lots of policy.
It's very, very complicated.
But yet, you know, some
miracle, the whole thing works.
So anyway, these things go
through from autonomous system
to autonomous system.
So what's this
path vector, right?
Remember, I told you
about the path vector.
The path vector is
a sequence of paths.
So it could be 3,
17, 26, and so forth.
So I have an animation
of this thing.
So I want to show that
to you because it's
totally interesting.
So there's this website called
[? BGPlay, ?] if I can find it.
So there's a way to get
MIT'S route advertisements
over the past month.
And you can kind of see
how these stats change.
So anyway, what
happened to YouTube?
What happened to YouTube was
the government of Pakistan
decided that what
they would tell
Pakistan Telecom
was to not allow
their users to go to YouTube.
So what they did was,
rather than simply drop
those requests, they wanted
to get Pakistan Telecom, when
somebody clicked on a YouTube
link, to go to a website
that Pakistan Telecom would
run that basically said,
you're not allowed
to use YouTube,
but would you like to
see something else?
OK, so the way they did
that was, they decided--
YouTube has some address.
Let me call YouTube's address
Y something, something.
Let me just call
it Y, all right?
Y is a set of IP addresses
that correspond to YouTube.
It's not one, they
have many machines.
So what these guys did was,
they did something they thought
was very clever.
They have a whole
network of users there.
They decided they
would advertise
a route for destination
Y inside their network.
But rather than use the actual
route advertisement for Y,
they would actually send
it to their own machine.
So remember, they
changed the routing now.
They're telling the users--
they're hijacking the route.
They're telling their users
that to go to YouTube,
you should not use
the actual link
that I'm telling you
to use, but instead,
go to this other place
inside my network,
where I can show you
this other website--
maybe pretend it's
YouTube, or whatever.
Now, everything is so
far so good, right?
I mean, people do
this all the time.
When you go to a hotel or any
internet kiosk, internet place,
you take your laptop,
and you go to cnn.com.
And the next thing you see
is, would you like to sign in?
How does that work?
Well, that works because they
essentially hijack the route.
They make it look like
you're going to CNN,
but in fact, you're going
somewhere else, right?
After all, your computer
wrote to go to CNN.
And the IP address used
was presumably CNN.
But then they made a mistake.
Some guy here-- probably,
he was too tired--
set up a configuration.
So he advertised
his new route to Y
that he created out to PCCW.
Now, PCCW was to
some degree at fault.
Because PCCW should have known
to some degree what actual IP
addresses Pakistan
Telecom owns, and only
honor route requests,
route advertisements coming
from those things, right?
PCCW needs to know
how to go, how
to send packets to nodes
inside of Pakistan Telecom.
But clearly, this
guy has nothing
useful to say about how to
send packets to YouTube.
But yet, this guy
honored this message.
So there were two mistakes here.
Actually, there
were many mistakes.
But the two big ones were--
there was a mistake made
here sending something out.
There was a mistake made
here honoring this request.
By this time, you
have transitive trust.
Because PCCW would find--
And what they also did
was, they made this a more
specific prefix.
So YouTube was
advertising a slash--
I believe it was
slash 21, which meant
it was many, many bits in the
prefix, 11 bits in common.
And there were-- sorry, 21
bits in common, a slash 21.
But these guys
advertised-- to guarantee
that all traffic would come in,
they advertised to slash 24.
So it's more specific.
So what happened was
PCCW believed that,
and they advertised
that to their ISPs,
and then to their
ISPs, and so forth.
Now, the reason why
this really got--
all of the internet's
traffic were
sent toward this
poor guy in Pakistan
was because everybody is doing
this longest prefix match.
And it's true that
there's a legitimate route
to YouTube in those routers.
But they're ignoring it because
they find a more specific route
that somebody had advertised.
So if you want to get
traffic sent to Google,
figure out a way to
convince some bigger
ISP to take your route to a more
specific prefix that you know
is owned by Google, and
just advertise it out, OK?
You're probably going
to get a lot of traffic.
Now, you may not want all the
traffic, but you'll get it.
So you see how this
stuff spread, right?
How do you solve this problem?
All right, this is going
on, and then people
are not able to see their cats.
And they're--
they're scrambling.
I mean, this is literally
the whole internet
wasn't able to get to YouTube,
which admittedly is not
the biggest problem
in the world.
But still, if you're YouTube,
this is a big problem.
So how do you
solve this problem?
What do you actually do?
I mean, the whole
world has this now,
this bad entry in
the routing table.
Now, there's this long-term
solution, which is of course,
let's figure out a
way to authenticate
the advertisements, and use some
public key, and this and that.
And you'll study this in
6.829 and other courses.
But today, we don't have that.
And this problem exists, so
how did we ever come out of it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, actually--
you know, it's interesting,
you and I--
you certainly thought
about this in 30 seconds.
But YouTube actually did-- it
took them a while to figure out
what was really going on.
Because one of the
problems is, you
don't want to do something like
that without knowing for sure.
But eventually, they
did exactly this.
They figured out the prefixes
that were being advertised.
And that took a while, because
you don't know somebody
else's-- what's in
your routing table?
I don't know.
I have to pick up
the phone, or email.
And email may not work because
it's coming back to YouTube.
But whatever, there's a way--
there's a way to figure this
out, phone and [INAUDIBLE]
Gmail or something.
And then they figured
out what it was.
And then they inserted slash
25 that were more specific.
And then once the problem
kind of resolved itself,
they got out of it.
So let me jump on and move on.
Give me two more minutes,
and I'll finish up.
A similar problem happened
with China Telecom.
They didn't advertise
a more specific route,
so they only got about
15% of the internet.
And they were nice enough
to forward it around
to the actual destinations.
But this was a problem.
I'm going to skip
through the decade
ahead because you know what,
you'll find out soon enough.
All right, what I
do want to do is
to summarize 6.02 in one slide.
This course was about how to
design digital communication
networks, right?
I'm sure you all
kind of know that.
We did this with three
layers of abstraction,
very simple story--
bits, signals, and packets.
And I think as far as
these kinds of courses
go across the world, it's
a pretty unique storyline.
There aren't very
many courses that we
know of which have this vertical
study across all the layers.
And there are some
schools that we
know of that are starting
to adopt this idea.
And we feel like this
is a pretty unique way
in which to teach
this, because it
demystifies all of the layers.
So we didn't cover
anything with-- we
didn't tell you 15 ways to
solve any given problem.
But we told you one good way
to solve each of the problems
that you will see.
So we went from
point-to-point links
to multihop
communication networks.
And across these
different topics-- and you
can see that we studied
these different topics.
The two big themes that
I want to leave you with
are reliability and sharing.
Because that's really what makes
our communication systems work.
How do you make it reliable?
We don't have a perfectly
reliable communication
medium at any layer.
So how you make things
reliable is important.
We studied this
over and over again.
And how do you share?
Those are the two big topics.